i'm kashish co-founder and co-ceo of
hi-touch excited to share with you a
presentation about data apps and the
caveat i want to give everyone here is
that i'm by no means the expert on data
apps so would love to get questions from
the crowd on like what you guys kind of
think data apps are we're here with a
proposal we just want to kind of discuss
like this is what we propose a data app
is and then get ideally the community
during the office hours an hour from now
to really talk about how they're using
data apps at their companies
and at their products and really like a
lot of the presentation is going to be
sharing about
how other companies in the space are
implementing data apps and what vendors
exist right now in the data app space so
just really sparking ideas i think we're
really nascent in the field of data apps
today um and where we could be in five
years is way way more exciting than
today so super excited to share and
uh welcome to the telecom edaps
oh i look like oh cool sorry
all right nice
all right yeah i'm cushing's co-founder
and co-ceo we started hi-touch about a
year and a half ago and we're the
reverse etl kind of like
leader in the space we get data from any
data warehouse into any sas tool so most
commonly you might have something like
trino
databricks snowflake
bigquery and you want to get that
bigquery data into your salesforce or
your subspot and that's really what we
do and all you need to make the product
work is a sql query or a dbt model so
given that no code we'll just get that
data into your crm and power any sort of
product or marketing workflows that you
have
so yeah getting right to it what is a
data app
we're defining a data app as any app
built on your data warehouse instead of
a transactional database and what that
means is the primary data store or the
persistent layer of the application is
your data warehouse and so usually you'd
have like snowflake
as the place where you're storing all
that data or
name any data warehouse here instead of
snowflake
and the idea is that can we use
snowflake as the persistent data store
for applications that we build so let's
say we're building a crm or help desk or
an order management system can we
actually build it on top of snowflake
because guess what we already have
snowflake in our companies and that
means it's really easy to spin up the
data's already there we can bring our
own schema and build some sort of ui and
like user interface on top of it to make
it all work for business users and
maybe even external of our company for
our end users that are purchasing our
product and so as a
there's a really good primer on this
and it kind of discusses how data apps
are the future because the whole idea is
that we already own this data store and
we have full control over it so
instead of having to transform my data
into users and objects accepted by
salesforce or some other tool i actually
get to say
accept my schema as it is and just build
an application on top of it and
me as a data user or someone on the data
team can ideally spin up these data apps
without any new like front-end
development work so the idea would be
that you simply define sql queries or
different ways to um like interact with
the operational database or in this case
the analytical database and
draw data from that database as needed
so why is it so simple like it's because
of the ability to
use your single source of truth in your
company so this
data warehouse already exists and
already has the data in it so instead of
creating replicas of the data warehouse
into different transactional databases
you simply just use the original and
that means you're not maintaining all
these different replicas as silos that
might diverge from the original and so
you get complete consistency in your
data which is
like just a very very nice thing to have
in a company um
that lets you greatly speed up your
development so instead of again setting
up a postgres to make it make your
applications work for your internal
tools
you ideally would just run right on top
of snowflake
potentially even deploy on top of
snowflake so that's like a promise of
snow park that has not fully
materialized yet but we're very excited
about because in theory you can host
your code on snowflake as well and host
your entire ui or something um
and then like what's more interesting to
us is really like the data team has
control over this and so instead of
relying on product engineers and people
to write api calls for everything more
and more can be based on the actual data
warehouse to store that business logic
so you could say that a transformation
is actually how we transform like total
amount spent rather than like having an
api that counts how many transactions a
user is made
and so like a lot of people ask should i
be building data apps at my company and
my answer is usually actually you
probably already have data apps like any
consumer of the warehouse actually is
probably building some sort of data app
but we're just not calling it that yet
because it's not like a full-fledged
product necessarily that someone else in
your company is using but you probably
already have those um i wouldn't say
that it's something that everyone needs
to build tomorrow it's much more like if
i have a good use case for it then i
might want to build one so for example
if i want to do some sort of like
enrichment where enriching actually
makes way more sense to do through the
data warehouse rather than through some
api that's when you might want to build
a data app um as an enrichment layer on
top of the on top of the data warehouse
[Music]
and of course there's many prerequisites
to making this work so it means that you
have a data warehouse etl some clean
data and transform data in the data
warehouse and it usually means that like
your data team actually has a lot of
context on the business and what they
want to do with that data so
most people here i think are already in
that mature data stack or like a mature
data journey but if not then there's
many prerequisites for being able to set
that up um and so as i mentioned the
consistency is the biggest pro
you never get diverging data if your
data is always based on one data store
like your bluehost and
like it works really well with the
modern data stack so assuming you
already have something like dbt models
it would be very easy for you to create
a new model to create a new materialized
table that then any consumer of that
data app can use as like an actual ui
within the application so i might have
some
user database and i want to provide my
customer success team a ui to see all
orders made by specific users and so
through a data app they could easily
click on a user's email address and then
see all orders and you as the data team
would simply have to materialize the
table for giving all user orders sorted
by their user ids and so that that's the
kind of thing where it's like the
business logic can actually be stored in
the warehouse in the form of
transformations rather than api calls on
different tables that are like just
creating joins every single time
the cons on the other hand are actually
pretty plentiful which is why data apps
don't really exist in practice too often
today and so like the number one and
number two reasons are
in an in an analytics database like a
snowflake or bigquery you usually can't
do transactions uh this is no longer
true snowflake actually does support
transactions now but for all intensive
purposes warehouses don't support
transactions and so if you're doing like
two different operations you can't
necessarily maintain that both
operations finish um
every single time and not just one so
like a good example of this is let's say
i'm transferring money from one big
account to another bank account um i
would want to make sure to subtract 100
from one account and then add 100
another account and if only one of those
two operations succeeds and the other
one doesn't then now someone has too
much money or someone has too little
money and there's like something wrong
so transactions in that format like you
simply cannot enforce invoice data
warehouses snowflake now does support
this so they're quickly working on
building the infrastructure that makes
data apps practical and that's again why
like snowflake is a pretty exciting
partner to work with
um
performance for obvious reasons
warehouse queries oftentimes run slower
than transactional dbs you get um you
can't do constraints so if you wanted to
do like a foreign key on another table
you actually can't enforce that foreign
key you also can enforce things like
cascading deletes and so that can cause
divergence as well in a transactional
world um and you can't search by ids so
in the example i gave you where i said
show me all orders um by some user id i
wouldn't be able to query the warehouse
every single time it's to say like give
me user id because she should hightach
io give me all orders
because that would get really expensive
snowflake would scan all users every
single time and then charge you like
dollars probably per per time you're
asking for each user so it would be
impractical from a cost perspective and
a speed perspective but
with a caching layer it is possible so
that's what i get to a little bit later
so again data data warehouse is the
primary stream of data and
the interesting thing that a lot of data
apps do today is the actual caching
layer so what you'll say is that give me
my data warehouse um replicate little
parts of it into a caching layer and
then let me make a production
application on top of that caching layer
and that way i can get the benefits of a
transactional db where it runs pretty
fast and i can do reads
with good speed and lookups with good
speed but i don't have to worry about
having a replica that diverges from the
data warehouse so
i still say like i would still call this
um based on the data warehouse like sure
the data warehouse is not the only
persistent data store there is a cache
in between but as long as that cache is
like a carbon one to one replica of the
data warehouse then i think for all
intensive purposes we should unconstrain
it and say that data data data apps
should allow caching layers in between
and so that is actually how like
companies like hex preset a lot of other
companies that we consider data apps get
by with faster read times and still have
a very consistent flow from data
warehouse um
and oftentimes what they'll do is
they'll say let me update this cache on
some schedule like every 45 minutes i
want to make sure that anything that was
changed in the warehouse then
materializes back into my application
where the server sits that serves the ui
and the front end actually doesn't
matter it could be on the warehouse it
could be off of the warehouse it could
be in your own like on-prem it doesn't
really matter
because what we really care about is the
persistence data store being the data
warehouse and then
there's this kind of like debate about
whether a data app has to have right
ability to the warehouse or whether it's
read-only or whether it's both and it
actually exposes a pretty big flaw in
data apps which is let's say i want to
do rights
those rights might take an hour or
longer to materialize and then other
users of the data app to see that exact
result right so like again let's go back
to that orders example let's say
i refund an order or i place another
order
how long is it until my data app ui
actually sees the results of that new
order and then another example is let's
say um me as a user data app i can go
and click like um
refund user i can click something like
like um give this user a free pay plan
for three months other users of the data
app may not see the results of that for
like another hour or two because they
may have to require a lot of
different models to materialize test
cases to pass then it's written to the
warehouse then we read from the
warehouse to our cache and then we see
it so rights are actually like a big
fundamental flaw right now for data apps
and that's actually where we think like
a lot of improvement can be made in
terms of being able to create like
basically like production layers on top
of the door houses that can be used for
both reads and writes and then replicate
back so like oftentimes what you might
see is someone might actually create a
table specific to their data app and
then use that table
and always replicate it back to the
warehouse so it almost needs to be
bi-directional in that way and i think
that's a big gap right now on data apps
that we would love again for the
audience to like kind of shed some light
on into like how they think rights can
be possible
um and then open questions that we have
is how do we reconcile like the fact
that like updates need to be fast enough
to reflect in the ui so like most end
users are used to something like 100
millisecond latency for them to click a
button and then see an action happen um
in a data app world that may not be
possible so you may have a user again
like place an order and you may not see
that order for an hour and for an
amazon.com customer support rep that
doesn't work
they need to be able to see that order
instantaneously in case someone is
flying a support ticket right afterwards
so
things like order management customer
support there's a lot of use cases that
actually are not well supported by data
apps today and like later on i make a
case for why aggregations and like
general like
like kind of data on like multiple users
is actually a much more common
application for the apps
and then the next is like which
warehouses do we use to build these um
is it like any warehouse is it
specifically warehouses that are meant
for faster reads is it only stuff like
click house that's like truly like
almost transactional in nature
and that's still open-ended
we can't say that we've built data apps
outside of
the perspective of high-touch so we
would love to again like get
ideas from the audience there
um
and yeah i'll skip over this slide
because it's really just making a case
for why data apps are becoming
interesting or popular it's because
warehouses have gotten so much faster
and because of the separation of storage
and compute because
now you can simply say hey i can run
this query instead of in five hours i
can run it in five minutes which means
that it would be practical to make an
application on top of this and maybe now
i do feel comfortable spending the money
to replicate this data every hour
because all of the operations are not
going to cost me like
a team of 10 data engineers to maintain
my hoodie cluster for me so that kind of
accessibility difference is making a big
difference and then shout out to
companies like materialize firebolt and
click house for really really going
cutting edge on how fast a warehouse can
be and helping like people like us think
about data warehouse is almost as
transactional in nature
materials are doing something definitely
interesting which is incremental
materialized views and so that actually
does solve for what i was describing
where if i write something back
will i have to materialize the entire
table every single time or can i just
incrementally materialize the parts that
are relevant to this new data and with
materialized framework it actually can
so
materializes here definitely take a look
at their booth and like talk to them if
you're interested in this incremental
materialization it's super interesting
in the way that they do it
right so now for the interesting part
there are actually a lot of people that
are considered
data apps today and this is a little bit
of a road map of the current vendors
that we kind of recognize the data data
apps again this was written in the blog
post that i linked on the first slide
and so we got like finance tools crms
product tools and security and again the
fundamental nature of all these tools is
that they're built as warehouse native
it's like warehouse native is popping up
as a term that people are liking to use
around like oh my app is based on the
warehouse and therefore i'm never going
to store your customer data or your data
at all in my database it's going to be
always in your warehouse and i'm just
going to build on top of your warehouse
so streamlit is kind of like the
hallmark standard for like what helps us
build data apps um it's kind of
interesting because like snowflake just
bought streamlit
and it shows snowflake's commitment to
helping people build applications on top
of snowflake um streamlight is a bit
different though because it primarily
helps people with bi use cases as far as
i've seen um and again
i would love to see like cases where
there's other use cases too but
primarily it helps you build uis on top
of your existing snowflake data and it's
pretty elegant like you simply like a
couple lines of python and now you get
your snowflake db as a db that you can
use to put applications on top of and
then the rest you can run in python and
you get like a nice django app if you
want so
it's
super nice in terms of being data
engineer friendly um but
interesting interested to see like what
people actually do with it in terms of
like helping end consumers or and
business users actually like use data
warehouse for like new applications
uh hex is another company that we've
seen do really well they've raised the
series b that they announced yesterday
and they're building data science
notebooks on top of the data warehouse
um and again this is super fun for us to
use because like we're internally right
off effects because um really like given
the warehouse you can run both code and
sql on top of the warehouse to be able
to run any sort of analysis that you
want
and instead of re-running all of the
past queries every single time they'll
be able to run just the parts of the of
the computation that are relevant to
changes that you make so they have like
pretty elegant like ways to
optimize how much you compute on data
warehouse but fundamentally for the end
users what's interesting is
i now get access to the data warehouse
as if it's like my local machine and i
can write computation or code or queries
on it pretty pretty simply um so just
really easy for brainstorming new
equations or the new data science models
preset
is
actually the cloud version of apache
superset and so originally it was
primarily a bi tool but where it gets
really interesting from a data apps
perspective is to use preset from
embedded analytics which is really the
direction that they're trying to go into
so
i'm hi-touch i have all these users and
they use my app and they want to see the
data about how many data points they're
syncing or how many times they're
running into errors
and basically get analytics on their
data so preset could actually generate a
dashboard an individual dashboard for
every single one of our users and say
here's how many data points you've
synced how many failures how many
matches et cetera and they could let me
embed analytics into my app where the
hydration engineers don't have to write
any front-end code and they can simply
provide a query
and preset can insert different users
into that query and as a template and
say all right show me the dashboard for
this customer versus that customer so
embedded analytics i think is like
something that gets pretty exciting
xflow is also in this space um
and i think it's just gonna streamline
how much data teams can actually build
product that end users see rather than
data teams
most of the time building kind of like
internal dashboards
um
retool i think in the past we would not
have called the data app but recently
has been becoming one
because you can basically build anything
you want in retool and read from the
warehouse so sure there's no right layer
um if you want to write anything back
you have to write a rest api in the
retail world but you can build crms out
of retool you can build like like custom
support adobe tool really like anything
on top of the data warehouse
and it will let you write javascript or
sql on top of like basically like like
anything so uh it's infinitely
extensible which means it kind of does
everything and nothing at the same time
um but we use retool internally we've
used it for like four years and
like if you have any internal tools you
need to build um and you have a
snowflake or a postgres already working
retool can probably do that for you in
like 10 minutes so that's exciting from
data apps world i call this more like a
streamlit in some ways because it kind
of does anything
and it leaves the user to imagine what
they want to do
this is probably the most contentious
one
do we count bi as a data app and i don't
know the answer to this question because
in some ways
looker doesn't have any data store it
just pulls from your data warehouse and
it does build you dashboards that
business users can look at and they can
do filters on to see like important
information
um and then if they want to use that
information they download a csv and then
they can upload that csv for some
purpose right so bi
by our loose definition could be a data
app um and so you could count looker
mode uh et cetera as as data apps but
we've had this for a very long time so
maybe that means data apps are not
really anything new but the speed of
access is just increasing
um
plg crms are like
basically the new age sales force um and
these are those we're pretty excited
about so like just for anyone that
doesn't know what pogcrm is it's a
product led growth crm and that
basically helps you as a company with a
lot of product users come in and say hey
well i have all these users can you help
me identify which ones are likely to buy
or likely to convert or having trouble
in my app and getting into all these
errors and i need to reach out to them
so pqls mqls and sqls they help you
identify those and then get a sales rep
in front of using those so
the interesting thing here is that by in
order to do this they etl your warehouse
into a postgres and then from that
postgres they run in the focus app and
then there's a few more of these end
game correlated variants are all
different pogcrms and they're all
tackling it in a bit of a different way
but the reason i mentioned focus here is
because pocus is warehouse native
whereas the other ones are oftentimes
using segment data or like other data
like from salesforce um focus is based
on the warehouse so i think it's a
little bit better for like more
enterprise
or like mid-market companies that have a
data warehouse um
and where it gets interesting is that
your
sales users or sales ops users can
actually define a pql or a metric
without having to go to their data team
every single time so this is both scary
and like interesting because you may not
want that like sales users to find their
own pql score you may want to own that
pql score in which case you probably
don't want to use this plg crm for
everything you want to write that into
the warehouse and let the pgcrm pull
from the warehouse but if you are a user
that wants those sales users to have
complete control over what is a pql and
i'm realizing that actually two logins
is enough for a pql i don't need four
logins they can just go and change that
in two seconds and boom now they have
more pqls that is actually exactly why
you'd want to use something in focus and
it is a little bit black boxy in the
analytical way but it's really useful in
the business user way
um
indicative uh recently purchased by
emparticle and particle is here too so i
think they would love to talk to you
about them is basically like amplitude
on the warehouse um and it's truly
warehouse native as well where like
instead of having to send all your data
to amplitude amplitude stores it for you
and then you get a nice dashboard and it
looks out of it
indicative simply plug and play into a
warehouse bring your own schema
and it will work for both events data
and object data so um super interesting
from a product's analytics perspective
and that's kind of like
a good articulation of the dream right
imagine if like no longer do i have to
collect events on my website and store
them all in like amplitude as well as
segment as well as like all these other
places um and i can always just forward
them all to the warehouse and i can
expect that as long as i get everything
in the warehouse i've done my job and
product teams will use indicative to get
their analytics marketing teams will use
something else those teams will use
focus all these other teams will just
consume the warehouse data in some other
way and my only job is to get in the
warehouse that's kind of like the
promise of data apps which gets really
interesting from data teams perspectives
and then we got panther um panther is
like security on the data warehouse and
it also works kind of out of the box
and would be interested to see like
who's using panther too because we
actually don't know as much about this
application
but we kind of see it as best in class
for security um
that is controlled from the data
warehouse data
epo is a newer tool for a b testing
and a b testing is interesting because
it's very similar to feature stores but
just a little bit different and so the
idea here is that you could actually
write which test class a user is in into
your warehouse and then
apple would serve that for you and then
get that data for you write it back to
the warehouse for you and then be able
to basically use your warehouse as your
optimizely or as your layer or as your
launch darkly or being able to do a b
tests um and that's actually like
kind of makes a lot of sense like
there's not really a reason why you want
to send all your like a b tests to
launch directly have launch directly run
them for you and then tell you the
analytics there like if you have a
warehouse already it's pretty easy to
compute that data
into like a and b in your warehouse and
simply run it from there so again it's
like every single one of these apps that
we see
we see them skipping like a layer of
development so the data that i have to
then etl into like launch darkly and
then maintain there i get to skip that
step and just do everything on the
warehouse so that's like really just an
expression of velocity that we can just
move faster with the
um
and then these are like notebooks or
like documents on on bi so
some of them are pretty cool in terms of
ux because you can write about text sql
or code and it'll turn that into
different dashboards um and so i could
it's almost like little attack or
markdown where i'll just write
everything in markdown and then in there
i'll add some sql queries or some
dashboards and every time it computes
it'll compete with the most recent
metrics um and so imagine instead of
making a board deck
as a data team you can just make a
dashboard and it updates every single
time so by the time they open that board
deck two days from now or four days from
now it has the newest data because it's
always just pulling in from the data
warehouse
also like notion could be replaced in
theory by something like this where it
has live data updates
um
cool and then where we get excited is
like what is not being done already so
vendors are helping us use the data
warehouse in new ways um and it's like
it's a good starting point but
internally in our own companies we could
actually build data apps that are
significantly more interesting
so imagine if like we were to build a
crm on top of the data warehouse and no
longer needed salesforce because we have
all our data here we simply just need to
build like uis for sales people to tag i
own this deal or they don't know this
deal and then be able to reach out
forward emails et cetera
that's actually kind of what retail does
in some ways and people do use retail as
a crm
i think there's probably in the very
near future going to be some vendor even
outside of plg crms that's going to
build an abstracted crm on the data
warehouse and so if anyone's looking for
a startup idea i think that's a pretty
solid one where why don't we build an
abstracted crm that follows any data
model so instead of just requiring
contacts and leads
i can have anything i want and i can do
different actions or the same actions on
those different objects um that gets
pretty interesting um
there's a new tool called supergrain
supergrain is actually building kind of
like the braze or iterable on top of the
data warehouse as the data warehouse
native app and so it's basically an esp
just in the traditional sense all the
prescribed uis but instead of having to
send the esp all your data it just plugs
in place in the warehouse so i think
super game is probably going to be an up
and coming playroom space too
then um the metrics layer in some ways
um is kind of like a data app um if you
use it like properly to actually like
enforce like other things downstream so
um everyone probably knows here like the
metrics layer is where you would define
aggregations or like different metrics
something like a churn score or a
propensity to buy score
even something as simple as total
purchases over time
and in that metrics layer because you've
defined those values then other data
apps or other tools can pull those
values and say all right i know there's
no column for like total purchases or
propensity to buy but this metrics layer
has shown me how to access it and so
i'll just create a metrics layer which
will create the warehouse and always
give me the right data and the right
metric and helps me have like one
revenue metric rather than 17 revenue
metrics in my company um so the metrics
leader kind of enables data apps at the
same time also in the same time
um
and where i get pretty interested is
like thinking of like building feature
stores or like any sort of place where
um
you could sort of ml models or serve
like feature flags off of the data
warehouse and so in the original world
right we would have a snowflake or some
data warehouse we would etl that
into postgres or some product team would
use that postgres or user launch darkly
and from that launch directly to
postgres you would serve your feature
flags so i would say okay you're my user
that has access the enterprise plan so
you get like
four destinations and then you only have
one destination and that's the
difference between both of these two
users and i'm going to serve the feature
flag off of this um off this launch
directly or this postgres
um
in theory there's no like i don't want
to like ruffle too many feathers but
there's no real need for launch darkly
in the data warehouse world because in
theory all your feature flags could be
like written into launch darkly and the
only thing you actually need is for your
production app to be able to call an api
and be able to ask all right what
feature flags does this user have
and so that's where the data app comes
in where it can say all right i'll store
your data warehouse table in a faster
database like a mem sql um and i'll
update it every hour and that way your
feature flags are up to date every hour
and now i'll use this mem sql to power
my production application and that will
have very like really solid latency to
let me serve the feature focus
instantaneously but as a result now your
data team owns the feature flags instead
of your product team and they can
determine which users are able to get
which feature or which or which ones
don't and so that's where it gets really
interesting because then you just reduce
the middle man there's not really a good
reason to pay launch directly if you
have like a postgres in your company
that you can just use for this purpose
um and i think that's another big space
for like a company to exist which is
really being able to build good feature
flags or good like feature stores off
the data warehouse data robot's kind of
in the space um which i mentioned is
kind of in the space but no one's really
doing it as a infrastructure play it's
kind of like very vertical it's right
now
um
yeah so why does high tech care about
data apps um so loosely we have like a
data app within high touch called high
touch audiences so as you guys know
reverse etl is use the sql query to get
data replicated from the data warehouse
into other applications like salesforce
hijack audience is actually very
different so high-tech audiences take
something like the schema defined by
metrics later and says because you gave
me these metrics i can actually give you
a point-and-click ui where people can
define user subsets or user audiences
and
it works for kind of like any user in
plain english so instead of having to
say all right give me users join on
orders based on this id and then now i
have users or all orders by all users um
it simply just says like all right give
me users that place an order in the last
30 days and then i'll show you those and
you might be able to say all right
what's the sku for those orders and show
me all users that order something purple
so
by the related object which is an order
which has a related object which is item
i can query all users that had purple
orders
of items that were purple in color and
now i can create a facebook audience out
of that
and i can even enumerate that i can say
give me all colors of the rainbow so
it's like royjib
give me a user audience that ordered
items of each of these colors and upload
seven facebook audiences to facebook
that expressed users that ordered purple
users that ordered yellow orange and so
on and that way i can market new purple
products to people that bought purple
and so on so it's like a bad example of
like where you kind of open up the data
warehouse floodgates to users that might
need to access that data to run
campaigns and that was just the ads use
case you might want to show them
tick-tock ads you might want to show
them emails push notifications text
messages pretty much anything that a
marketing team might want to do
you can power using high-tech audiences
and the reason we call this data app
still is because there's actually no
caching layer in between um it really
does simply take your metrics layer um
take this point and click ui where you
define like all right users that put
object in card but did not buy um
and then let's you compiles that into
sql and runs that sql in the warehouse
every single time
so each time that audience computes
it'll ask the warehouse all right show
me all the users that did this and then
it'll send it over to some sas tool um
and
it's almost like you could call each of
the different use cases like a facebook
ads use case as like one data app and
then like maybe like an amplitude use
case a different data app um because or
like maybe there's a salesforce task use
case and that's another data app so it's
almost like more of a framework to help
you build data apps in your company by
exposing
business users that have these campaign
ideas to be able to build their own
and that's what's exciting for us um
there's this new product that we're
launching in a few weeks called
high-tech traits which lets people
kind of like define their own traits on
users so again like i might want to say
like
a user that logs in like more than five
times is a high high value user or a
high like high propensity to use user
and so i can just define that trait and
hydrate audiences and use that column
for many different things and like in
another audience i can ask for that
trade which is a number of logins as an
aggregation
and trades actually links one to one
with the dbt metrics layer and asks like
all right if you have the dbt metrics
later we'll simply just take all your
trades from there um and if you don't
have that then we can help you create
those but it kind of like makes bag
for the more sophisticated companies
using dbt you kind of get it to work out
of the box which is really nice
and lastly um
there's this concept of like creating a
notification stream off the warehouse
that gets pretty interesting so like
let's say you have a user that signs up
um can you get a slack feed of all users
that sign up or can we make it even more
interesting so
user workspaces that grow past 10 users
maybe we should get a slack feed of that
that goes to our account executives
telling them hey all accounts with more
than 10 users should be on the business
plan and so here's the feed of all
accounts that upgrade to 10 users
go sign them up for the business plan so
that kind of notification feed off of
the warehouse is actually something
users have been doing with hydrogen for
the past like year and a half ever since
we started as a company and it doesn't
fit well into the constraints of reverse
etl because when you think reverse ctl
you think of copying the user's table to
another user's table somewhere else but
creating a notification feed out of the
slack is much more like a data app it's
much more like all right i have this
database or this data warehouse and what
can i do out of it to like empower
different use cases and in this case
it's the
pql use case of getting people that are
product qualified in front of a human
being at my company so i can go reach
out to them from a sales perspective
so that's where it gets really
interesting and fun uh for our users we
didn't think of these use cases our
customers kind of came to us and said
hey what if i could get my warehouse
data into slack and then our engineers
were like yeah sure we can do that and
we developed a completely new frameworks
for doing this which is like the reverse
etl framework is object object and
there's a notifications framework and we
even have like an event space framework
which is like event forwarding almost
from your data warehouse so
love to talk to you guys about all this
kind of stuff like in our office hours
because it does
get
more complex but then way more
interesting because you're not creating
new replicas you're actually creating
use cases directly off the warehouse
and then there's ecosystem enablers like
streamlight and snowpark that are really
making like data apps more accessible to
us so like i don't have to host my own
data app anymore if i want i can just
use streamlight to host it for me um and
that's that gets pretty exciting because
otherwise you have to spin up aws and
host your data app there and watch it
and make sure it doesn't break so that's
super nice and then snowpark um
theoretically at some point will allow
you to host code on the snowflake server
itself and i have the ui hosted there so
i would i'm excited to see how that
plays out because i think again that'll
just make the layer between like the
warehouse and the application layer go
like just get like significantly thinner
and thinner and thinner until it's all
one big thing which is why like
warehouses are calling themselves like
the what is it called the data app
ecosystem or like the data cloud rather
than the data warehouse because they
have a server component now too
um
yeah i think we kind of discussed this
already but it's kind of far away for us
to think that everything will become a
data app so for because of like the no
transactions and because of no um like
foreign keys and so forth it's pretty
hard to imagine that we would use data
apps for everything
we can imagine using it for things like
embedded analytics because it's okay if
those analytics compute every hour
or for things that are like aggregations
like i just want to see
which product category is selling the
most in my company and i can see that in
my data app so for use cases like that
that are based on aggregations is pretty
practical for read-only use cases again
it's pretty practical because the
caching leader can cause fast reads but
for write use cases it gets pretty
complex
and that's where we're hoping that like
more infrastructure will be developed
here over time
and so until then i think like
that's kind of where reverse ctel fits
in for now where right now you put you
use reverse etl to get data from the
data warehouse into sas applications um
because it's almost like a i don't want
to say some optimization but it's almost
like the practical way to do things
because you need that data in salesforce
or braze or or um
or iterable and so it's kind of like
over time we'd expect more and more
analytical use cases to be data abuse
cases and then more and more business
use cases to be reverse etl
um
and
it's yeah and i think it's a little bit
far away before this becomes a true
reality
and thanks for listening to the talk
we'd love to take questions from the
crowd